so today's topic is controls of the
center and center squares and our first
game is an example of how control of the
center is going to lead to a much easier
game better space more chances to win
the game and eventually winning again
the player who played in the white with
the white pieces is no other than Garry
Kasparov which I'm sure you've heard of
he was a world champion for ten years
and one of the best players in the world
even now that he's retired he's still
considered one of the best players and
his opponent in this story in this
competition is a player that was from
Yugoslavia back when Yugoslavia was a
country in 1992 his name in miserable oh
he's a chess grandmaster we know so you
can see his rating is over 2500 is a
veteran Grandmaster but you could see
that even against a grandmaster if you
manage to control the center and prove
that the way he sets up his pieces is
not ideal you can still win even against
a much higher rated player watch what
happened in this game again the opening
might not be something that you
necessarily play but still I want you to
kind of have a flexible mind about it so
9 f3 again sometimes white doesn't know
if he wants to play efore or d4 he wants
to be a little more mysterious so this
could be a good opening night f6 also
very flexible waits for white to see
what he does c4 so now we have some sort
of an English with c4 g6 g3 again there
are many ways to play you could also
play Knight c3 and try to play d4 and e4
many ways to play very flexible g3 c5 ok
so black basically is saying I want to
play a symmetrical English symmetrical
because everything is kind of looking
the same right now if you folded the
board in the middle everything will fall
into place exactly the same Bishop g2
Bishop g7 pawn to d4 of course white
wants to have some claim in the center
and he immediately wants to trade the C
pawn for the D pawn so because right now
who controls the d4 square it
like he has a pawn on it right now white
plays this move and he takes over the
control of the d4 square so in this
position normally black does one of two
things either he takes the pawn like
this like pawn takes Knight takes let me
show you well he could castle as well
but okay I'll just go with castles
castles and here he played 986 but
normally and this could happen on the
move before as well
you can play C takes d4 Knight takes d4
this machine is always talking I don't
know why
we'll have to shush it one day night c6
and that's a normal way to play towards
the center fight for the center inner
event you can see that here both sides
are claiming some stake in some play in
the center playing fighting for the
center squares but here our opponent
from put black decided to play Knight to
a6 now we know that Knights on a rim
night on the side are not that good
night on a rim is grim we say and this
is one of those examples yes he is
hoping that at one time those pawns will
be traded and maybe his Knight can hop
to c5 the problem with c5 that that's
not a good stable square even though
there's a very nice diagonal right now
at some point at the right time white
can play d4 later to kick that night you
see that that happens in the game so
this was not a good plan watch out
Kasparov just plays simple moves Knight
c3 if we are pretending that we are
white in this position you can see at
the end of the game wow I could have
played a lot of those moves and this guy
is the world champion am i playing like
the world champion maybe the answer is
no but you will see that it's so simple
that you yourself can play very logical
knows okay
pawn to d6 very normal and now why it
says okay I've developed my three minor
pieces
three of the four I want to develop my
Bishop from c1 because the center is
good my King is canceled what should I
do with this Bishop I don't want to go
here because it's very passive I don't
want to go here because the knight might
just kick me I definitely don't want to
go here because if I went Bishop f4 then
the pawn will take on d4 let me show you
how it's done
and of course if you take back
then oops if it allowed to do it you can
see that this is just a fork a simple
fork attacking the knight attacking the
bishop bad news for white so okay we
don't want that to happen obviously and
we can't go Bishop eight six we're gonna
lose it if we go Bishop g5 he's just
gonna kick us with the H pawn and then
again the bishop has to make a decision
where is he gonna go he can go he is
gonna get trapped and he has to go
backwards the bishop has no good moves
on the diagonal that is very simple
therefore Kasparov very wisely played
the move b3 he says you know what you
have a very good Bishop on g7 that is
controlling all this important diagonal
I am going to put my bishop on the same
diagonal and have something to balance
that other mission very simple and smart
play by casparo so Bishop g4 again he
says okay I also want to develop my last
undeveloped minor piece let me put it
where I'm attacking the knight because
where else can I go that's a good square
and okay
Bishop b2 the game goes normally Queen
d7 this is what we call a battery a
queen and Bishop on the same diagonal as
a battery sometimes the queen is on
front sometimes the bishop is in front
here black wants to play Bishop h3 and
that will get him to trade that good
Bishop for that so so Bishop
so after Bishop here I'm going to be
able to trade it so why it says I don't
like that I don't want to trade I want
to preserve my bishop therefore I'm
going to take one tempo to move my rook
to a pretty the okay square e one and
now the idea is if you brought your
Bishop to h3 my Bishop is just going to
go back and hide on h1 and we're not
trading Bishop I'm keeping my good
Bishop again you see that very smart
plane just really pay attention to what
your opponent does you do what you want
but you also pay attention to your bonus
threats and you respond in turn so rook
to b8 he is thinking maybe I'll have a
chance to push my beep on and get some
things moving on the Queen side at some
point so Kasparov says Queen d2 again a
very logical move think about it it's
like we learn how to play chess develop
your minor pieces so all the one the
white minor pieces are the Val
control the center with your pawns and
pieces he did that castle he did that
and now he wants to connect his route
and develop his queen and he does now
again very easy to understand moves by
casparo so in this position there are
all kinds of ideas for example one idea
that's worth mentioning if he takes in
the center Knight takes and he brings
his knight to c5 then white plays the
move efore and just by looking at the
position you can tell that white is just
much better he has more space and look
how beautiful his bishops are two pawns
in the center around the center the
knight is beautifully placed this Knight
at some point is ready to just jump to
d5 in the center and of course all of a
sudden this bishop looks a little clumsy
what is he doing here what is the bishop
doing is just like on an empty diagonal
maybe at the right time I'm gonna kick
it and he's gonna be really confused of
where to go so yeah this is looking very
nice for white therefore he decides to
take that night he says let me get rid
of this Knight and the problem is that
he is giving up his good Bishop for a
knight and now you'll see that Kasparov
maintains an advantage now when I showed
this game to my students they all say
okay Bishop takes and I take back with
my bishop but Kasparov said now I am NOT
going to take when I bishop I'm going to
take with my pawn even though it looks
really funny and sometimes it's wrong in
this position is the best and here is
why
by taking with the pawn he succeeds in
doing several things one he opens up the
file for his rock - he is going to add
the F 1 to F for controlling the center
even more from the sidelines so he
doesn't really block his Bishop he's
going to open it in just one second and
this is just very smart way to play so
pawn takes excellent an excellent move
really really good so rook e8 already
black is starting to feel like his pawn
on e7 is not very well defend only the
Queen is defending it and there's a rook
all the way here so he says I wouldn't
have an extra protected otherwise my
queen will never be able to move for
example one idea that white can have
at some point if those pawns get traded
is to trade Queens and then this one is
just going to go so you really have to
be attempted so you played rook e8 and
white played f4 just like promised
because right now his bishop are late on
g2 is a bit sleepy and this pawn is not
doing much by advancing it we can see
the control of the center so watch
what's happening in this game White has
two very good bishops but so far black
doesn't have any weaknesses and we
didn't lose any material it's not like
oh my goodness black is just losing now
but you'll see that step by step
Kasparov is improving his position and I
think he will enjoy seeing how that
happens
so pawn takes d4 sooner or later he has
to take those platform because otherwise
what is his Knight doing on a6 so he did
this and he did this and he did this and
now again it's a beautiful position
where you could say Wow Aviv aren't you
wasn't Kasparov afraid of this bishop
being right opposite the Queen all you
have to do is move this night somewhere
and then maybe the bishop is gonna
attack the Queen said that means the
knight can move anywhere he wants to
shouldn't get part of just like movies
Queen to d2
so Kasparov said nope um I don't have to
I have a reason for it and I'll explain
it to you guys in a second he said okay
what should I move now I want you guys
to also participate with me the Queen is
okay I'll prove it I'll prove to you why
the bishops are doing a good job the
pawns are doing a good job
one rook is on a semi-open file on a
half-open file here which piece is not
playing which one of our pieces is still
sleeping tell me
that's right and what does he do brings
it right into the best center square on
d1 so you might say okay this move I
understand but what happened if now
black plays the move Knight e4 it looks
like this is a very unhappy movie for
white because look the bishop is
attacking the Queen and the knight is
protected by the other night so the
Queen can just take anything and if the
Queen moves then black might trade and
then trade is just going to get rid of
all the pieces we don't want to trade
pieces when we have a space advantage so
why would Kasparov allow it well he
allows it because he has a beautiful
tactical trick let's see if anybody can
use their imagination again notice that
yes the bishop is attacking the Queen
but notice there's also a bishop here on
the long diagonal and watch out all the
pieces are kind of hanging there's a
rook opposite this Queen that's also
plays a part and here white is a very
good way to continue how many of you
think that they might know you have to
use a little bit of imagination a little
bit of guts because the next move is
like whoa can you really do that and
when you keep calculating you see that
yes Kasparov prepared the devilish trap
yes well not exactly if you play 90 X 9
my Bishop will take your Queen right and
then it's not a good trade because you
get two minor pieces that I would six
for your Queen that's worth nine right
but if you got three minor pieces there
are worth 9 for your Queen that's what 9
even though it's 9 for 9 it's gonna be a
much better deal for you because what
can the Queen do by itself right now it
can't just do everything by itself but
three minor pieces together and suck out
a machine it's like a whole team of
pieces so how can we get all the three
minor pieces because black only has
three left he has a bishop and night and
another night how can we get all of them
for our Queen what do we need to do yes
okay let's count let's say you take this
night and let's say I take your queen
then what not enough right not enough
you have to be you have to be a little
more careful than that how are you gonna
get to pick up this guy this guy and
this guy for the Queen I want to take
all of them yes to where to e5 to d5 but
then you just lose I'm just gonna take
your stuff here wait if you go Queen d5
I'm gonna go Knight takes c3 not good
right you lose
yes exactly correct
very nice again guys don't be afraid of
moves that look ridiculous and chest you
have to have a flexible mind you have to
think sometimes a little bit outside of
the box and this is what you're doing
Queen takes g7 yes I know the Queen is
work 9 the bishop is worth 3 but watch
what happens the King has to take now we
got a piece for the Queen but it's not
over the bishop is on this long bag and
also what do we do go on yes check this
Cup exactly the bishop is checking the
king
so we already got 2 pieces for our queen
well the King better save itself let's
say the King goes backwards what can you
do I guess that and now continue exactly
Knight takes e5 very nice Kenda pond
just take back that night not unless you
want to lose your queen for nothing
right here and be done a lot of material
so we can see that the Queen will have
to move and white managed to win three
minor pieces for the Queen sometimes the
Queen is really good against three minor
pieces when they are clumsy and when the
position is open and they and the Queen
can just take stuff but here the Queen
can do nothing nothing I mean the three
pieces located two bishops they are like
two x-rays just shooting like two laser
beams and all I have to do is just go
back with my knight probably I will play
my knight like to here here and then put
it here and then the whole structure is
going to be very very bad for black
so of course this is just winning for
white alright of course a grandmaster
will not fall into this trap he knew not
to play night before and he played
instead b6 okay he wants to protect his
knight and defend everything now that
this Knight is protected by this one as
well you have to be a little careful
that maybe Knight fe4 is coming so
Kasparov says let me go right ahead and
attack it Knight d5 I'm positive that
all of you can see the Queen and the
bishop is that on a battery like we
learned before it's a battery on the
long diagonal if the knight takes the
knight queen takes bishop is checkmate
so now also white is another little trap
let's pretend for a moment that this is
white to move well let me just play some
silly move for black let's pretend black
plays this just for fun now White has a
beautiful little sacrifice how do we do
that the idea is to play rook take C 7
that is a tremendous threat because
after rook takes a 7 Knight takes f6
check and then after this we just take
here and you can see that this is just
checkmate how do you stop the maid here
or here there is just no way no way you
can stop it you can stop one of the
mates but not both well actually I don't
even know how you stop this maid period
so this is checkmate so that is the very
very very strong threat and therefore
black had to do something and he played
96 he is hitting the Queen so there in
blocking the file and the Queen just
went back to heat you
very good square it's controlling the
center and the King side the Queen side
already we can tell Kasparov strategy
was very very smart he has a beautiful
knife in the center he has more space
and his two bishops again like two laser
beams one from the right one from the
left but you might say hey Aviv that's
really nice but that doesn't win the
game yet show me how you win the game
keep watching so Knight takes d5 well
sooner or later you have to get rid of
this 9 you just can't allow it also
White was just now threatening Knight
takes f6 Jack and what do you take with
the bishop and we trade or you take
immediately with
porn at the end you will just lose this
pawn so you got to do something about it
and he took and took back attacking the
knight denied us to move he moved to c5
normal now on we go Bishop takes g7 very
good King takes before kicking the night
because the knight has no good squares
to go to where is he going to go he
cannot go to e6 you cannot go to e4 you
cannot go here you cannot go here so he
has to go either to b7
but then when where when and where is he
gonna go to where nothing the bishop
that just now is going to be stuck
forever you will never be able to do
anything so not good if you go to a6
also what's the next move backwards so
he tried to move 94 now I'm not saying
this is great but I came blame him for
this move because otherwise he would
really have nothing so I said okay first
of all let me put my queen on the best
score of the board on the board check
and the King was sent back and now he
says okay let's see my queen is very
well placed my rook on e one is having a
lot of fun on this file my bishop is a
bit weak right now but I don't know what
to do with it just now I don't know how
to improve it just a second but I see a
beautiful C file especially with the
most delicious square on c6 see if I put
my piece here I'm gonna have all the
space in the world
so rook shifts from v1 when the default
they're just closed to c1 very very good
so a five black is trying to get some
activity and he is really hoping really
really hoping that maybe white will
trade that pawn because if he trades
that point that would be a terrible move
for white because after trade trade the
knight will be able to sometimes get
back to a c5 square this time without y
doing anything about it okay so why it
said nope I'm gonna just protect it with
upon I have to have a pawn on b4 as long
as I have a pot on before your knight is
never coming back to the game the way he
wishes so takes takes b5 again hoping to
maybe bring the night to b6 and c4
so I'd say no not rook c6 beautiful move
not only is he keeping the night stuck
where he is but also gaining a ton of
space
look how strong this rookies on c6 right
in enemy territory
so route b7 f5 again a very very smart
move white can play many good moves here
for example h4 is also a good move and
it's coming very shortly because after
h4 we want to play h5 make this King
side look a little weak also have an
escape square for the king
so f5 black took it and white took this
pawn again very very nice notice that
this is a trick if you play pawn takes
rook I will take your other rook and
that will be checkmate very nice okay so
he moved his rook and now White has to
move his and that was blacks idea
because now he wants to jump back and
stop that very annoying beep on all
right
so h4 very very clever
notice how thanks to this Center control
white is completely dominating in the
center he can do anything he wants on
the Queen side he can do anything he
wants on the King side and black is just
stuck now I'm going to speed up just a
little bit so we can see what happened
the Queen went back and he played h5 d 6
was also possible but h5 the idea is to
once but for one thing we want to
threaten this structure the second thing
we want to play a move like eight six
and then all the dark squares are going
to be really really weak so Queen to e8
now the idea is if you play h6 I'm going
to play Queen f8 and start bugling that
pawn so why it says okay I can play
other things you play Bishop h3 the
bishop is improving its diagonal very
very clever Queen f8 black says listen I
can't stand this the Queen on d4 is just
killing me I want to bring my queen to
g7 and trade it I have to get rid of
this Queen so white goes King G 2 this
is
a bit slow he could have done other
things but again Kasparov is in no rush
so King g2 Queen g7 and now of course
black was saying well maybe maybe he's
gonna trade that's gonna be really nice
maybe he's just gonna go away with his
queen that's also gonna be nice white
said now continuing his complete control
of the center look at this
rook pawn queen and even this query that
is not has nothing on it it's completely
in white's control black has nothing the
whole centre is in White's control
that's why he's gonna win the game so he
played he could have played Brooke
afraid that's not helping he played he
six and white simply played Queen III
beautiful and this is the point in the
game he went Knight B to tried to get
his Knight into the game finally some of
you might say wait a minute why didn't
he just take this guy and the reason is
rook to c8 is very very strong just a
monster little move after which there's
just nothing you can do
I'm threatening you Rach I'm threatening
to play rook to e8 winning your queen
and if you take and I take with a bishop
I'm attacking the rook and I'm
threatening rookie a Czech winning the
Queen game over
so quickly so he can't do that he knew
not to do that so he played Knight b2
and white played 86 hitting the Queen
the Queen went out pawn takes pawn
already winning a pawn and look at the
King side no fun he played Knight to d1
yeah that's not maybe not the best move
but who can blame him I mean it's really
terrible Chuck takes Queen e2
moving away from the threat King f8 he
doesn't like his King to be made it but
now white played Queen takes d1 the last
move of the game and black had to resign
why because of course after rook takes
simply look to see eight and the game is
over
the only legal move would be to play
queen blocking the check then my rook
can just take it and I have an extra
bishop and extra pawn and at that level
they know that there's just no I'm not
telling you guys to resign if you have
just down a piece it's worth playing on
but at that level you resign did you
guys understand this game good now let
me show you one more example very quick
example not a game but rather a position
that one of my favorite positions to
show to show the class I'm gonna run
through the opening super fast so you'll
see how we got there but then at the
right the critical moment I'm going to
stop again the player in this game is
another world champion vasily smyslov
and he was an ex-world champion now you
see that he's playing an opponent who is
a little lower than him we're playing a
Sicilian and normal variation everything
is normal everything is the way that's
supposed to be and normally in this
position nowadays black knows that he
needs to take this pawn he has to trade
and then he is to develop his bishop
that's normal he tried to develop his
bishop immediately and now white played
here the bishop came here and now watch
what happened let's take a quick look at
this position to understand now
everything is about the pawn structure
it's a blocked pawn structure here but
this is a really bad pawn this is a
beautiful square for white because there
are no black ones that can get to it but
the question is how do we get our pieces
to here without being traded our dream
position would be if we can put a knight
a bishop - but especially a knight on d5
that will stay here forever and which is
the worst black piece to have against
this Knight if you had whitey you have
to say okay pick one black piece to be
left at the board would it be this
Knight would it be this bishop or will
it be this bishop
which of the three do you think is the
piece that's going to be the least able
to defend against a monster knight on d5
what do you think
our Bishop on e7 that is correct because
it has nothing to do with the light
square it's a dark square bishop he will
never ever in his lifetime be able to
get rid of that the monster night so
watch what Y does
step 1 let's get rid of that Bishop
because that bishop controls the light
squares okay
so the Queen Chuck what do you think the
next step should be here how do we get
rid of something we need we want to
bring the knight to d5 but right now
there's an idea that that light is gonna
just take it what do we need to do what
is the smart move here yes correctamundo
exactly right fantastic move Bishop g5
when you look at the position here and
you don't think about what's important
you may play one of a million moves you
might play Bishop back you might bring
your Queen to h4 you might move your
king
you might try to change the Queen away a
million things but when you understand
you immediately see what's going on I'm
dying to get my Knight to d5 if I get a
Knight to d5 it's gonna be like an
octopus Knight it's gonna have eight
moves and if you go in every direction
forward backward sideways King side
Queen side so Bishop g5 well normally in
the color position the knight would love
to go away so that later on when the
night comes to defy maybe I can
challenge it again but I can't just move
my knight because my Bishop is not
protected on e7 okay so he brought the
route here now he is ready to move his
knight what do we do how many of you
think they know the next move for white
I'm expecting everybody to have their
hand up and to have confidence believe
in yourself remember what I said I want
to have my knight on d5 without any
black minor pieces that can disturb it
so that means what do I need to do right
here and right now yes of course Bishop
takes Knight sometimes we really love
our bishops and we're not gonna just
trade them for Knights for no reason but
in this specific position in this
structure you must take the knight you
want to take the night and after takes
back
hop the night jumps directly into the
center some of you I think wait a minute
don't we have to protect our c-pawn
first no because 95 if you take the C
pawn in the game you just move this
Bishop if you take the C pawn right here
then after rook f2 I'm going to attack
the queen and protect my other beep on
the Queen will have one of two choices
now it's screaming either to go away
from the C file then I'm gonna play 97
forking the two rooks and winning a look
for a night or if you stay on the C file
then I will play rook to c1 kick the
Queen when it moves away then 97 and
white wins material and the game so you
realize they cannot take the pawn so he
moved this bishop away he's trying to
maneuver his bishop maybe to the other
side of the board but now why it said
okay let me protect the pond so I don't
have to worry about it all the time
because now that c7 square was covered
and now you will see why White has a
winning position even though he is not
even up one point why because in this
position you can do whatever you want on
the Queen side on the King side in the
center and black has no counter play you
cannot generate any play watch how the
game continues b5 black is trying to do
something active but you'll see that it
doesn't work
okay b3 rushing the Queen away Queen c5
and now why it says okay what is weak
the queen is right here the rook is
right there the bishop is here if I cut
the board in the middle like I always
like to do the King looks quite alone
let's get some white pieces around the
black King move the King away because it
was a Czech rook c8 and rook f3 now we
begin the Brooke is coming of course we
have to move the King from check first I
forgot about that but immediately after
that the rook is lifted up and I'm
intending to move the rook along the
third-ranked so what to do you can play
the move f6 but if you play the move f6
right now then I will start playing
moves die
g4 and I'm gonna bring my queen and my
other rook over and h4 and g5 and all my
pawns are going to I'm going to
basically play on five ranks and you're
gonna play on three and I'm going to
eventually open up the position anyway
so so in the game he played King h8 and
now the King is really alone in the
south on the side of the board white
played very smartly with f6 an excellent
move this is just coming up everything
starting to completely demolish the King
side what did you really really trouble
if you play something like g6 I'm gonna
go Queen d2 put my queen on h6
threatening all kinds of mate and if you
stop this mate my rook will just swing
over to here and I'm gonna make you so
the Queen in the rocker just gonna kill
the king
so he had to take it you see that taking
where the bishop is exactly the same
because in a second he's gonna have to
trade that Bishop for the night anyways
so Queen h4 beautiful very very clever
no rush to take the point the point is
not going anywhere if you push the pawn
forward I'm gonna play nine f6 very
similar to the game so it doesn't matter
at all but now I'm flirting to play 90 X
F 6 xx x h7 mate black is trying to
defend like this but now why it plays
another monster move
rook to g3 beautiful first of all you're
saying if you go take my rook
Queen takes 87 is mate and now I have a
threat Queen takes 87 Luke takes 87 Luke
to g8 checkmate you've gotta get rid of
this Knight no choice
so he took Queen takes watch the
difference between the two positions I
have a beautifully active Queen monster
rock
you're a very passive pinned rook and a
queen can do much in a second I'll get
this guy into the game more chow
you have to defend here rook d1 all the
white pieces are working like a group
the black pieces are not working now I
want to just start take
stuff Black is very desperate he tried
the tricky move d5 he is kind of hoping
that either white takes to the pawn and
blocked the file or if he takes with the
rock Queen a3 threatening mate
of course even this is not really
impressive but white simply took on g7
and black had to take back or actually I
think he resigned here because yeah
because if he takes back then simply
rook captures d5 threatening the Queen
and also threatening rook to b8 mate and
if you try to bring the Queen back I'm
at least going to win your queen so game
over very good now the lecture is over
and they want you guys to play some
chess among yourself so please spare
yourself and play